we haven't done a state of the podcast
in a while and I think it's important
for the state of the podcast that we do
a state of the
podcast uh I'd be convinced if you had
just said stay of the podcast one more
time but I agree I think we should take
stock and um you know how are we doing
and I think also self-criticism is very
valuable uh it's good for us to really
kick the tires on this thing and make
sure that we're living up to uh people's
expectations how we proceed well as we
always do we bring in Adam Sachs he runs
this place he makes it happen he makes
it work he does the dance that keeps the
floor thumping yeah so Adam awful where
are we awful awful monologue wasn't yeah
so state of the podcast I brought some
notes with me we are 5 years in it's 5
years now November 19th 2018 was our
first episode the release of our first
episode so we are 5 years in over 400
episodes wow are we over 4 episodes I
believe that's right if we count the fan
episodes on our those are important yeah
so over 400 episodes and we're actually
seeing growth still which is pretty
amazing still seeing growth yes so
people have been listening to this and
more people are still showing up more
people are showing up and because the
catalog is so Evergreen you know the
episodes that we recorded 5 years ago
still are still hold up uh people show
up and then they go back and they listen
to The Back catalog so on a given month
we get 40% of our listens happening on
old episodes people are telling friends
but in a good way yeah in a good way
that's my first experience with that in
Show Business my previous career was you
got to check this guy out they're
warning people yeah uh so that you don't
accidentally stumble on him you need to
know no but uh that's I mean all kidding
aside that's very exciting uh I will say
that we made this decision to try and uh
and it's also just naturally the kind of
Comedy I like but we're not uh um we're
not always talking about the day events
and uh in fact anytime a guest starts to
say isn't it funny that uh today in the
news I I uh I reach over the table and
slap them yeah um Sam bankman freed was
just uh found
guilty oh okay well that's but the other
thing is totally that that totally
screws up I'm sorry I wasn't listening
to oh you don't mean that Sam man freed
okay you mean um the guy who has a
restaurant and guilty of serving a grape
Fried Chicken there that's Evergreen
that's always yeah Sam's Place come to S
bankman it's samman's fried oh fried yes
there you go there you go there I fixed
it now it's just you discussing uh yeah
it just he was just found guilty of
serving an amazing fried chicken yes so
check it out uh on lasena and
33rd intersection
y exist uh no I think that's there's
that there's also we're we're still
getting like crazy amazing guests that
you know are coming on for the first
time even recently we've had Arnold
Schwarzenegger Harrison Ford uh Steve
Martin Sir Paul McCartney Kelly Clarkson
you know what's great Schwarzenegger we
didn't even invite him he and we tried
to keep him out of the building he's
like I'm coming in
you're and we uh remember and I said no
no we're here we're talking to Ted dance
he's like it's now it's going to be me
and he smashed his way through
yeah incredible did you need more from
me so and the other thing I wanted to
bring up which is interesting is the
industry has evolved if we look back
five years yep if you think about the
advertisers we had at the beginning it
was mostly what are called direct
response advertisers Dr advertisers
where um oftentimes they're like digital
advertisers uh you know fracture prints
was a good remember the
backr yes and they have an offer code
right offer code Conan or you go to this
specific URL and that's how they know if
the ad is working it's attribution so
we've grown out of that now we still
have plenty of them but we've we've got
we've gotten into more Brands big Brands
and that's and that's I think listen I I
listen I like that uh things are moving
in the right direction but sometimes
you're the victim of your success and I
will say I miss I mean fracture that was
a great company do they still
exist uh uh yes no no no they do for for
Conan's 60th birthday I got him a
fracture print can we just edit that so
it's
40th uh and anyway um at the same
age uh but you know it's you know it's
uh thank you no uh it's it's fun being
well I guess I'm 41 now um so there's a
thing that can happen sometimes in life
where yes you've had good fortune but ah
you missed that old little apartment you
used to live in in remember where the
shower didn't quite work but boy did we
have good times in that old little and
that's how I think of the fracture print
ads well it's funny you say that because
the brand so now we have a lot of brand
advertisers we have you know Miller
Light Chevy these big brands that don't
have and by the way those are terrific
products they're fantastic uh but brand
advertisers so director response
advertisers don't necessarily they're
not that sensitive about the content
that they're advertising on they just
for the most part care that the ad Works
they want the ROI the return on the
investment so do you ever spot speak
normally I know I'm getting somewhere
this what it's like in the bedroom yeah
but brand advertisers really care about
associating with Talent right and so
they do what they have been doing more
and more is brand safety analysis and I
actually brought some uh brand safety
analysis for needs boy you're fun at a
Holiday here's my question though cuz he
was on television for like 20 years
before the podcast that brand wasn't
enough well that's that's a good
question so you can see how we rank here
thanks son this is this is funny
okay all right so this is uh and this I
think this is mostly I I believe what
what is this now explain what's can you
take a second explain what this is so
this is our brand safety analysis that's
done I think primarily by like Ai and
transcription so transcription is done
on the podcast and then some algorithm
decides how brand safe the show is this
is real this is real these are our Real
ratings on the show and so brand advert
when they're deciding whether they want
to advertise on a specific podcast will
look at these ratings and decide if the
show is safe for them to be associated
with okay all right so medium uh adult
sexual explicit content that seems low
is that that seems very low says it's
dicks and stuff oh but down here
obscenity and profanity it's in the red
for 83% and 71% highrisk yeah so we're
killing it with obscenity and profanity
maybe this is just all our clinical talk
whenever we vagina hate hate speech
7% That's you acts of aggression that's
oh oh acts of aggression I don't like
because there's no hate speech here but
there is me routinely trying to take a
swat at somebody you're also crime and
violence cuz you say the word murder on
a regular basis I mean you're 11% high
risk wait a minute military conflict do
you want to just run down what the sheet
says to give us kind of an overview of
those adult and sexual explicit content
4% alcohol 2% these are risks high risk
zero for suitability crime and violence
12% wow death or injury 3% relatively
low remember one time we did a segment
about robbing a bank and what would our
masks be so that's things like that
factored in okay uh death or injury 3%
epidemic 3% hate speech and acts of
aggression 7% it's a little high for me
illegal drugs 1% we don't really talk
about drugs a lot yeah we do but
they're not illegal everything you do is
legal yeah that's true uh obscenity and
profanity
83% wow geez jeez zus Christ that's
a high number tobacco East
cigarettes vaping 0% well now it's going
to be in there though does will it
Factor this oh yeah now it's going to be
in there is this a category violation of
Human Rights oh that's just us working
for you yeah that's that's you it's a
violation of human rights to work work
here and that's 1% um I don't understand
military conflict yeah what is military
conflict we talk about World War
II the term Nazi will pop up every once
in a while I think it's I think it is
like just talking about basically World
War II facts trivia Stalin comes up a
lot but is this a concern that us
discussing these things right now will
bump these numbers up I hadn't thought
of it but and next year when we do this
again it compound I think so boies
boobies Nazi
but I think so the truth is like this is
more Sona made a really really important
point which is like you were on TV for
28 years your brand is established you
had advertisers on that show so it was a
brand safe show your brand safe Talent
this really is more done for talent that
is maybe lesser known to you know
advertisers if they're when they're
making the decision if they want to
advertise on a specific show I see but I
did think that you would just find it
interesting that we're being analyed
what you take away from this I actually
take away that um there is a high
sensitivity among advertisers now higher
than ever it seems to be associated with
brand safe content so I think for us we
should just be monitoring your language
primarily everyone's language here um
and thinking of these categories every
time we go into an interview or do a
segment no but but
um uh if I'm told not to do something I
just want to do it more Adam you're
coming dangerously close to being the
man censoring the artist here so also I
don't think I use profanity I mean
cockaroo is that a is that really
profanity I don't
know I love that answer I love the way
you said it I don't know well there was
talk of deral is all kind of not unless
you really get into what it's all about
I don't think this thing understands
context either it doesn't understand
context so talk of Geral is quite a that
could be a a children's story but it it
could take take Geral and think Joseph
JBL and make it a Nazi thing you know no
that's Geral well it's written in a
transcript it doesn't know it does it
knows the difference they're spelled
completely differently it's ridiculous I
think the state of the uh the state of
the conflict I think the state of the
our numbers are going up on Military
conflict I think the show is doing well
are Marching forward uh we're like the
Allies pushing in uh to to
France we're we're we're pushing forward
we're uh moving our way we're
penetrating okay that hole we're having
sex with the other
Army listen don't ruin a good thing I
I'm pleased I feel this a good thing I I
do nothing but say uh I have gratitude
that we've been doing this for 5 years
I've been having a very good time I I
doing this with you uh with you people I
got to learn your names uh but um and I
think we should maybe tone down uh the
PE PE poo poo a little bit language uh
and um you got a face I but I do
want us to you know keep getting uh more
and more brand
friendly I I really do I I want to just
keep chisling away I want to I want to
but pee PE and poooo is what we are
that's who we are as people
this what a wonderful story this is no
but that's that's just what we who we
are I feel like you're you're telling us
to change i' like the Hallmark Channel
to one day advertise with us and I think
to get that and probably also uh
Disneyland so to get those kind of
Brands those are the ones I really want
we need to really sh I think we
definitely need to check back in we need
to do quarterly state of the podcast and
see the trend of the numbers can we do
that yeah 83% yeah that's high it's red
83% obscenity and profanity let's get
that number down and let's get
um let's get violation of Human Rights
way
up I don't know how but we
will